Jake I gotta tell you the engaged life  is amazing especially sexually well I  don't want to pry it up right I want you  to know this No  vivy and I have a wonderful intercourse  itinerary that we have planned I'm  usually more of a chocolate guy but this  one's closer so I'm gonna buy gky  that's habanero pepper frosting because  her marriage is going to say Oh unless  you think it's a bad idea no sounds like  a great idea Oprah to one okay be kind I  don't have a models body like you come  on show me what you got Fred Astaire  Gene Kelly Liberace  Diane Keaton Roger that okay Charles  you're not Scottish yeah get back in  there brave our summer linen suit casual  a classic actually not bad one question  can you see my underwear ah song why are  you wearing a thong  it's my Something Borrowed get back in  there  you